welcome to the take this evening with me
Jane second live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster well it has been
quite the seven days since the last
program a king ground and an
extraordinary set of local election
results today the controversial illegal
migration bill is making its way through
the Lords with plenty of opposition
including from the Archbishop of
Canterbury another piece of legislation
the recently passed public order Act is
also under the spotlight following the
arrests of protesters ahead of the
coronation but it's that thumping for
the conservatives at the council
elections that sets up the political
battle ahead with a general election on
the horizon can labor really win a
majority and will they do deals with
others if they don't plenty to get stuck
into as we bring you takes from all
sides over the next 60 minutes
it is isolationist it is morally
unacceptable and politically impractical
well that was the Archbishop of
Canterbury criticizing the government's
illegal migration bill in the Lords
meanwhile in the Commons we're getting
on with halving people's energy bills
freezing fuel
filter
okay and boosting pay well he's well
he's busy plotting coalitions we're
getting on and delivering for the
British people
the Prime Minister there sticking to his
guns but those local election results
put a bit of a spring in case numbers
step
this is the price of having a tired worn
out government
how does he think the tourists can
possibly provide the answers Britain
needs when the whole country has already
told him they're the problem not the
solution
well it was real knock about stuff at PM
Keys today and plenty of important
questions for us to get into this
evening with my guests
well on the show we'll speak to the
immigration Minister Robert genre
also the chair of the labor party
Annelise Dodds plus we'll talk to the
conservative MP Ben Bradley and much
more besides on the take
[Applause]
foreign
still has a lot of settling to do after
those local election results with the
big one a general election possibly just
a year away now it's been a busy day in
both the House of Commons and Lords with
plenty of politics and important policy
at play so let's crack straight on we're
going to start with the best bits of the
week so far
Metropolitan Police say it regrets the
arrests of six people during King
Charles's coronation Graham Smith he's
the chief executive of this group uh
Republic he was actually held for 16
hours in the end on Saturday he turned
around 150 million pounds
uh celebration of a institution that we
oppose don't just give me wild
speculation about numbers
speculation the police aren't
operationally independent of government
they'll make these decisions based on
what they think is best now placumri's
leader Adam price is facing questions
over his political future after a
damning review Into the party's culture
also potentially an impact on Welsh
labor who of course rely on applied
support on a corporation agreement you
must be worried about what the report
has said about the culture within
has explained that that's not my
priority Mr stalmer refused seven times
to explicitly rule out the prospect of a
deal with the liberal Democrats just to
be clear you're ruling out any sort of
arrangement with the s p and you are not
doing that with the liberal Democrats
I'm clear I'm pressing on I want a labor
majority government workable majority
the Archbishop of Canterbury has
criticized the government's plans to
stop illegal it is isolationist it is
morally unacceptable and politically
impractical to let the poorest countries
deal with the crisis alone and cut our
International Aid completed the
opposition
and this is the price of having a tired
worn out government fronted by a prime
minister who boasts he's never had a
working-class friend how does he think
the tourists can possibly provide the
answers Britain needs when the whole
country has already told him they're the
problem not the solution
is right we all do say some silly things
when we're younger I was a teenager and
he'll he'll know what I'm talking about
because I think in his 40s he was still
talking about abolishing the monarchy Mr
Speaker
[Applause]
well that was the commons let's start
with the government this evening a few
moments ago I spoke to the immigration
Minister Robert Generac and I began
asking about his brief the illegal
migration bill now going through the
Lords
in the Lords today the Archbishop of
Canterbury has been talking about the
illegal migration Bill let's just have a
look at what he had to say it is morally
unacceptable and politically impractical
to let the poorest countries deal with
the crisis alone and cut our
International Aid
were morally unacceptable politically
impractical how do you respond to that
well good evening the House of Lords is
doing its constitutional job as a
revising chamber and of course we'll
listen to to views of uh the Archbishop
and his colleagues but the British
public are clear they see the unfairness
in the English Channel and they want us
to take action because you've got mostly
young men in a place of safety France
with a fully functioning Asylum system
getting into small boats fueling a trade
in organized immigration crime and then
breaking into our country in flagrant
breach of our laws no country would
stand for that and nor should we that's
why we're introduced the illegal
migration bill at the heart of it is a
very simple principle that if you come
here illegally in that manner you will
be returned either to a safe country
where you've come from like Albania or
to a say Third Country like Rwanda this
is the only way to break the people
Smugglers hold to create deterrence and
to get back control of our borders
that's what the public expect that's
what we're doing the public certainly
expects a legal migration to be dealt
with but the point that the Archbishop
and others have made is that this policy
isn't going to achieve that it's it's
just not effective the home secretary's
written an open letter to the Lords
telling them this bill is the will of
the people
um but a lot of people just don't think
that your proposals actually are going
to make any difference well I
respectfully disagree I've spent several
months now immersed in this issue and I
can tell you that what makes the
difference is creating serious deterrent
ensuring that if you try to come here on
a small boat if you pay people Smugglers
you will not find a life in the UK you
will be returned back home or to a say
Third Country like Rwanda if there was a
simple solution we would have done it
already we're reaching for this because
it is robust but it's also fair and it's
going to succeed because it will produce
the crucial deterrence that breaks the
business model of the people Smugglers
and the human traffickers once and for
all and the Archbishop and others uh
raised the issue of morality well
there's nothing moral in perpetuating
the trade of the people Smugglers these
are amongst the most evil individuals in
society today and it's only by breaking
their business model decisively which is
what this this bill will do that we can
achieve that but Elders would argue that
the very easiest way to break that model
is to give safe and legal roots to the
people who want to come here no that
that is uh I'm afraid to say an
irrelevant argument because super
relevant if you can't come here legally
and then you're going to find another
way to come here legally in the last few
years in a very very defined small
circumstances no that that's not correct
since 2015 half a million people have
come to the UK for humanitarian reasons
whether that's from Ukraine Hong Kong
Syria Afghanistan or the global scheme
which is much broader and is operated by
the United Nations more humanitarian
visas were issued last year than in any
year since at least the second world war
so those are countries who picked like
Hong Kong and Ukraine well there's also
there's also a global scheme which the
UN operates where they choose who to
bring to the UK using their expertise
and we have a family reunion scheme that
helps those refugees who have family in
the UK to come here as well and 45 000
people have come on that scheme since
2015 and these are very large numbers by
historical and other European standards
for resettlement schemes we're second
only to Sweden for taking people from
the United Nations we're fourth in the
world so the argument that's made by
some particularly on the left that the
UK is somehow ungenerous or the
conservative government is not committed
to the UK being a Force for good in the
world and offering Sanctuary to those
genuinely in need is not true but what
is true is that taking predominantly
young men from France is making it very
difficult for us to continue to live up
to those high standards we want to focus
the resources that the UK has on the
people most in need and to break the
model of the people's Smugglers but what
is also true is that whatever you say
about your policy being the most
effective policy it's not the policy
that the voters seem to think let's just
look at this poll that we have which
looks at how people regard how the
government has dealt with immigration
how the government's handling
immigration badly the red line at the
top just look at this over the last
couple of years 83 percent of those
questions think the government is doing
a bad job of handling immigration we're
doubling down on that policy the way
that's why they want us to take very
robust actions
what we're doing here is something that
is significantly different what we're
saying is the Home Secretary as you said
I'm going to stop the boats and gone
down to to the coast and and well this
is just over the last three this isn't
just trying to deter this isn't just the
last three years this is a fundamental
change to our system it's saying that we
will be a force for good in the world
with resettlement schemes and safe and
legal routes but if you come here
illegally you will not find a route to
life in the UK that is a fundamentally
different approach to any we've done in
the past and I would just say to the
labor party or the lib Dems or those who
seek to criticize this approach what
would you do and I haven't seen any
credible policies from other political
numbers of home office workers to reduce
the backlogs that's gone up we're
doubling 70 000 to 166
000 in two years and it keeps going up
so as as the numbers keep going up they
say they there is the problem is that
the people who are here aren't being
dealt with quick enough well I want to
reduce the backlog and we've got a very
good plan to do that but the idea that
you deter people from coming into the
country illegally by saying to them you
know what we'll process your claim
incredibly quickly it is very naive
getting the backlog down is the right
thing to do and we're doing it we're
doubling the number of decision makers
that the home offers but you're not
doing but this isn't going to make
people not come to the YouTube other
countries by the labor party you've got
to be tough in this situation because
we're dealing with determined people and
Ruthless People Smugglers and human
traffickers that's why the kind of
robust but fair approach in the bill is
the only way we're going to get on top
of this issue okay let me move on to
brexit in the EU retained law Bill Kenny
badnox made it a statement today one of
the promises of brexit was to remove all
EU legislation by the end of 2023 the
business and trade ministers today said
the government's going to amend the bill
to revoke only about 600 out of the 4
000 retained EU laws was brexit worth a
paper it was written on it certainly was
and we have been doing it already in a
range of important areas we've already
set out to reform laws which we
inherited from our time in the European
Union but which we believe as a
sovereign country we can do better we've
done that in financial services we're
doing it with data like gdpr that
everybody who deals with in their daily
lives and now we're setting out to
remove from the statute book more of
those laws that we've inherited from the
EU and replace them with better more
innovative ways to tackle similar
challenges what we've said today is that
we're going to prioritize the most
impactful and ambitious laws and then
turn to ones which have far less impact
on society or the economy but they say
that you would cherry pick which laws
you wanted to repeal you know you said
that you would repeal all EU laws
well we'll just do the ones that we can
no we want to do that but it's obviously
sensible for a government to prioritize
and we're going to prioritize those laws
where we think we can make the most
impact in people's lives whether that's
improving environmental standards or
making our economy more Innovative and
successful and we'll do those first and
then we can turn to the others where the
impact is much less later on when when
you look at the sunny Uplands of brexit
that the conservative party in Boris
Johnson promised us before the last
election and how you did does it fill
your heart with Dread as we approach the
next election
no I think the British public were clear
that they wanted us to leave the
European Union we've delivered on that
and now this bill is an example of where
we're trying to use the new powers and
freedoms that we've got creatively to
support the British Public's Ambitions
and if I give you an example an area
like life sciences and exciting new part
of the British economy that can also
help the NHS to deliver Innovative
treatments we're going to be ensuring
that the UK has the best Frameworks it
possibly can to support scientists and
researchers but there'll be other areas
that are a lower priority and it's right
that we turn to those later on in the
process that's just a sensible good
government approach
we had the local elections last week
catastrophic by any measure really when
when it comes to how many seats the
conservative lost a thousand was touted
as a bad number it wouldn't be as bad as
that it was worse than that let's look
at the figures uh you lost 163 Council
seeds
um it's not very good a thousand and
sixty three I do I do beg upon um
how on Earth do you think this is going
to translate out into the general
election
well I don't think you can make a direct
comparison between local elections and
general elections and there are plenty
of examples where parties have performed
in a disappointing way in a local
election and then went online
well if you look in 2019 the last time
these uh local councils were up for
election there was a disappointing
results and we went on to win a big
majority later on in the year in the
general election nonetheless of course
we are disappointed by the results and
the loss of many very capable local
councilors including in my own
constituency but what we as a government
have to do is to focus on the issues
that the public really care about and
we've made clear what those are we want
to tackle inflation we want to get the
deficit down we want to support the NHS
by getting the backlog down there and in
my area in the home office we're focused
on securing our borders and stopping the
boats that's what we as a government are
doing because ultimately at the general
election people will say is this a
competent capable government that's
making my life better and we need to
focus on those big challenges now and
when you look at what's happened to the
economy over the last few months when
you look at this secession of
conservative leaders that we've had do
you think that people are going to think
this is the competent and capable party
hand on heart can you say that to me
well I know Rishi sunak very well and I
think he is the leader that we need at
this time eventually he is working hard
he's addressing the big issues he's
already stabilized the economy after a
very challenging period last year with
the war in Ukraine and the aftermath of
the pandemic and now of course we've got
to move forward and use this year to
deliver for the public so if I was sat
here in a year's time you would be able
to see that on the big challenges facing
the country we're clearly moving in the
right direction I'm confident in Rishi
and the team he has around him and we've
got a big task ahead of us
13 years do you think the general
population wants a government that's
moving in the right direction wouldn't
most people have seen that after 13
years you might have sorted it out well
we have achieved a lot in the last 13
years you only have to look back at our
track record in some absolutely key
areas like education reform for example
where we've massively increased the
number of young people in good or
outstanding schools there are areas that
we should be very proud of as a
government but latterly of course we've
had some huge Global challenges haven't
we we've had an unprecedented once in a
century pandemic That Shook the
kaleidoscope and meant that there was
immense pressure on our public services
and our economy we've had a European War
for the first time since the end of the
second world war which has led to a big
pressure on the cost of living Energy
prices
those are major challenges we're working
through them we're getting stability
back in the economy this year I think
will be year marked with inflation
falling significantly the economy
growing if we can also ensure that
public services are performing well like
the NHS and if my time ask we can make
progress on stopping the boats then I
hope the public will give us a good
hearing when it comes to the general
election but delivery is the key for us
now and that's what the Prime Minister
and I focused on Robert genre thank you
very much thank you
well a little later we'll get Labor's
taken all of that first let's see that
our Deputy political editor Sam coats
makes up what he's heard so far mark my
homework Sam look I just think it's a
bit glumbing a government Minister a
Tory representative at the moment look
you went through the numbers in that
interview of the number of council seats
over a thousand that they lost in last
week's local elections way worse than
the worst predictions by Michael
Thrasher and the ones that the
conservative party chairman went on air
uh to talk about but what was clear from
the interview with you is just how
little room for maneuver this government
is whether it's the shellacking that the
illegal migration bill is getting in the
Lords from possibly the most famous
cleric in the country uh Archbishop
Justin Welby uh whether it's the
problems that they're having trying to
reboot the economy whether it's uh just
the sense that
wherever you look this government is
going to struggle to try and introduce
new legislation that's controversial and
does reform he doesn't have a great deal
of wiggle room in the comments or to do
anything that involves spending large
amounts of money because there ain't
much money left the public finances are
very very tight so what is Rishi sunax
path for the next year or so when it
comes to any attempt of trying to win
the next election well they are going to
put all their eggs on the economic
basket you had a little bit of that in
Robert genrex way he was talking about
Richie sunac's success in stabilizing
the economy but the problem is for most
of that time inflation is going to be
very very high so you are going to be in
a situation where people are going to be
feeling poorer almost all the way
through to the run-up to the next
election
okay Sam pretty gloomy uh you're
watching the take live here in
Westminster up next we'll be talking to
the chair of the labor party annalize
Dodds
[Music]
welcome back live to Westminster this is
the take well let's get the view from
labor now on what's been a busy week in
politics a little earlier I spoke to the
party's chair and Liz Dodds
I've just been talking to the
immigration Minister Robert genre and he
told me that the government has a clear
plan to tackle migration the
government's plan is to act as a
deterrent to those who would give money
to the people's Smugglers remind me what
would labor do specifically to deter
people getting on those boats yeah we
would do many things differently to the
government Unfortunately they haven't
had a plan and actually this most recent
bill is just a warmed up version of what
they introduced before it hasn't
deterred it's actually led to for
example the people Smugglers actually
receiving more funds than they did
before the first thing that we would do
is we would stop the situation where
there's incredibly slow processing of
people who come over you know whether
it's by boats or other means only one
percent of people who came over by boats
last year have actually been processed
so vet Cooper has been Crystal Clear
we'd focus on making sure that we
speedily reprocessing people there will
be people who have a right to be here
obviously we've always had that
tradition as a country but where people
do not have the right to be here we
shouldn't see those cases going on for
months even years in many cases secondly
we would make sure the National Crime
agency actually had the resources and
the powers that it needs to crack down
on the people's Smugglers you know labor
has made many suggestions to Robert
generick and the conservatives about
what needs to be done there you know for
example we want to see the National
Crime agency working with other
governments and their services we want
to see proper action being taken with
the French government for example to be
really driving down at what's taking
place with those criminal people
Smugglers then the final thing of course
that we would do is have proper return
agreements with other countries you know
again something that the conservative
government promised to deliver that they
haven't delivered labor would be focused
on making sure that we had those
agreements but none of those concrete
legislation is it well it's concrete
measures that would deliver very rapid
change we've seen the conservatives
passing legislation which hasn't not
only made the situation any better it's
actually in some cases some would argue
it made the situation even worse you
know we had legislation passed last year
which the conservatives said would deal
with these issues it hasn't we've
actually seen the number of people for
example accommodated in hotels
increasing now that's terrible for
everyone you know it's awful for the
people left in limbo there but it's
terrible also for the taxpayer and it's
really expensive and every expert
analysis of what the conservatives are
setting out now suggest that we'll see
even more people being housed in those
kinds of hotels because of their
approach Labor's got a very different
approach it's a practical one to deal
with these issues we saw the BB
Stockholm that that accommodation boat
arrive on the south coast this week what
would labor do about that would you have
more of those or would you get rid of
them
well we would seek not to have more of
those kinds of facilities because we
would want to make sure that people will
actually processed speedily you know if
you look at what's happened over the
last 13 years you've not seen a focus
from government on this issue you've
seen those waiting times the ultimate
amount of time it takes from the moment
someone makes an application to when
it's processed just lengthening and
lengthening under the conservatives you
know that as I said is not good for
anyone labor would make sure that we've
got a grip on that that we were actually
properly fast tracking dealing with
cases properly you know we've done that
before actually when labor was in
government when there was an issue we
dealt with it we've not seen that from
the conservatives we've had a lot of hot
air but we've not had delivery
okay
um the election results pretty solid set
of election results for the labor party
uh you all seem pretty happy
536 Council seats up
do you expect not hope expect that you
will form a majority government at the
next election yes I genuinely do on the
basis of these results I think not only
did we see that lead for labor obviously
lengthening but we also saw that labor
was winning and with really big swings
in many of the areas that are critically
important for us forming that majority
government of course these elections
didn't include Scotland and actually in
Scotland we're moving ahead as well so
yes I do believe that we are on track to
form a majority government okay you
believe that
um the respected Sky News election
analyst Michael Thrasher says no he said
you would fall short 28 seats short of a
majority this is his prediction if we
extrapolate out those figures uh you can
see it there 28 seek short
um
this government has been mired in all
sorts of problems we've had three prime
ministers economically the mass of the
squeeze and income since the second
world war why do you think you didn't do
better than that well actually I think
that Michael Thrasher has been very
clear that certain assumptions fed into
his model you know particularly
assumptions around what like what's
likely to take place in Scotland and
Libra is moving forward very strongly in
Scotland we also didn't see of course
elections in London nor in many of our
really big cities during the set of
Elections so actually to be
extrapolating from the overall picture
in terms of a general election isn't
that helpful the most helpful thing here
is to look at the places where labor was
picking up support because they're
indicative of whether we're going to be
winning in those real swing marginal
seats and in so many of those places you
know Stoke Dover many many places right
up and down the country we saw labor
making games that were really pretty
large gains be sure we're on track for
that majority government but a lot of
people said they should have been bigger
and wonder what it is you know that
people are not voting labor for is it
policy is it personality or perhaps your
leader or is it the history of past
labor governments what do you think is
the thing that is putting people off
that perhaps should in your mind be
voting labor well I have to say I didn't
find people being put off you know I
campaigned up and down the country from
Swindon all the way up to Sunderland
during these elections I spoke with you
know hundreds maybe even pushing times
of people I don't know really very very
many people during the campaign and
before it and what I find overwhelmingly
was that people are feeling that
pressure from the cost of living crisis
every single day they don't have a
government that's taking action to
support them Labor's plans particularly
that plan to plug the windfall tax gaps
so that we could freeze council tax was
very popular on the doorstep so was our
plan of course to get rid of the non-dom
tax status and use that money to
massively boost our NHS Workforce so
people could see that labor was setting
out those Solutions we do have many
months of course it appears until the
next general election I wish it was
going to come sooner because I think our
country needs change right now but we do
have those months to come and Libra is
going to continue you to set out those
really practical Solutions with a
mission-led government and again when I
talked about that long-term Focus from
labor people were really attracted to
that compared to the sticking plaster
politics under the conservatives that
we've had for so long you said obviously
you expect that you will form a majority
government but kirstama seems to be
wavering slightly about whether or not
there would be a Coalition in July last
year he said that he is ruling out any
Arrangement any kind of Coalition with
anyone yesterday our political editor
Beth Rigby interviewed him about a
hypothetical deal with the s p
completely ruled it out so we asked
about a hypothetical deal with the lib
Dems he didn't rule out let's have a
listen to what he said
so you are ruling out a deal with the s
p on any terms but you're not ruling out
a deal with the lib Dems well as you
know with the asmp it's a fundamental
difference I do not believe in the
breakup and separation of the United
Kingdom just to be clear you're ruling
out any sort of arrangement with the s p
and you are not doing that with the
liberal Democrats I'm clear I'm pressing
on I want to labor majority workable
majority
we also not seven times and he only
wouldn't answer so a deal with the lib
Dems is possible isn't it if you vote
labor well actually what Kier said was
absolutely correct that he's aiming for
a majority government and you know it's
not Party leaders but that's why people
decide the outcome of this but I think
the question is what the electorate
wants and it's going to be there for
years is would would there potentially
be a coalition with a live Denver people
are going to vote labor they need to
know whether they're voting labor or the
whether the voting labor with the
possibility of a labor lib Dem Coalition
but what they can know very clearly is
that labor is determined not to have a
coalition government instead to have a
majority labor governments how people
vote at the end of the day in The Ballot
Box quite rightly as the secret ballot
they will vote how they want to vote I'm
confident that as people see what
Libra's setting out for our country that
change so finally we can have a Britain
that works for working people when they
see that that they will support that
majority labor government if it's
if it isn't a majority labor government
you're not ruling out that it could be a
coalition with the lib Dems you're not
ruining it out
what I would say is you know it's for
other parties to be clear if we have
that labor government but it's our labor
government yeah but if I can just finish
we have a labor government that's
setting out those plans for example to
scrap the non-dong tax exemption use
that money to boost our NHS Workforce if
we find other parties want to vote
against that while the responsibility
for it will be on their shoulders not on
Labor's shoulders because we're setting
out that perspectives for change okay so
he wouldn't rule out and you're not
ruling it out either and finally um in
in prime minister's questions today the
Prime Minister called kirstarma uh he's
already called him Mr flip-flop Mr
Softee call them Mr flaky today there
have been a lot of u-turns we've seen
tuition fees U-turn um labor now not
scrapping those re-national of the
utilities not so much there vowing to
stand with the trade unions barring
cabinet members from from joining picket
lines why should voters trust what is
written in Labor's Manifesto for this
next election when you've u-turned on
all of these things that were in your
last
because every election is a new election
when a political party will present a
Manifesto based on the circumstances
well every party always draws up a new
Manifesto I think people would be pretty
surprised if any party just photocopied
what had been there before these
circumstances are different and actually
care has been really open and clear he's
not going to have a kind of last minute
back of a packet frankly approach
that we've seen far too often with
policy announcements just driven by
politics we've had enough of that
sticking plaster start from the
conservatives he set out those long-term
missions they're unashamedly long time
he's clear it's going to be difficult
for us to achieve for example that goal
of having the highest sustained growth
in the G7 but nonetheless he's
determined that we as a country will get
there and he's setting out the Practical
measures to get there he's not saying
that it's going to be easy but it's been
very open about that fact this is going
to be a collective effort across our
country I think that's a really
different style of politics actually
that's coming from here it's one that's
respectful of people and that indicates
he's going to govern in partnership with
business with trade unions with local
government as well in the interests of
our country again a big contrast I'm
afraid with what we've had recently and
Liz Dodds thank you very much
this is the take live in Westminster up
next we'll look at the turmoil implied
gumri and give a back venture here a
chance to respond to the prime minister
[Music]
welcome back live to Westminster this is
the take the leader applied comrie's
political future has been thrown into
question following a damning review of
the party's culture Adam Price called a
special meeting of Plies national
executive committee after a report found
a culture of bullying and misogyny in
the party well let's speak now to a
political correspondent Joe Pike who is
in Cardiff for us and Joe will he stay
or will he go
we don't know and that is why Jane this
is chaotic it is far School we've had
now near 24 hours of pretty rampant
speculation that Adam Price has finished
he's off he is out and yet throughout
the day we've had radio Silence from
almost all members of the Senate uh for
ply Camry members of parliament and sort
of backroom advisors one statement today
from them saying there would be this
special meeting of the party's ruling
executive this delay partly perhaps due
to the fact that there is no obvious
successor to Adam Price certainly no
success if you discount those who've
already committed to standing for
Westminster and of course as we're
talking about the Welsh nationalists
they want somebody who has a seat here
in the Senate not who has a seat uh in
London in Parliament why does this
matter well partly cosplayed is the
third party here in Wales but also
because they have a cooperation
agreement with the government with Welsh
labor labor here only have 30 out of 60
seats they don't have a majority and
therefore they rely on the support of
ply to get more contentious legislation
through the parliament will that
cooperation agreement continue well some
questions over it tonight that the labor
party publishing a statement saying
there will be discussions about the
agreement in light of recent
developments what are recent
developments as you say that damning
report which talked to the a toxic
culture of misogyny of harassment and
bullying implied I think the Welsh labor
party realized they've got to look like
they take that report seriously and
they've got to have a view of the
culture within a party they are doing a
business within even if it's not a
coalition it is only an agreement that
meeting starts to be think around eight
o'clock Jane so we're maybe an hour and
40 minutes in it is still not over we
were expecting some sort of statement
perhaps suggesting The Way Forward
perhaps announcing Adam Price's
resignation but as yet no confirmation
from that so the k chaos the fast
continues
Joe thanks very much
now it's our regular chance to talk to a
back bencher as we pick a question to
the Prime Minister that caught our eye
during the prime minister's question
session earlier today it's this one the
Mansfield District Council now having
more conservative councilors than at any
point in my lifetime
last week's local elections are very
proud of our local team but one thing we
heard on the doorstep was frustration
um a frustrating expectation the
government needs to deliver on key
pledges there has been a commitment to
our part of the world that will be given
the clout the investment to catch up
with other regions that historically
have had more than we've had so all the
prime minister take the opportunity to
reiterate his commitment and to my
constituents reassure them that he will
support growth and investment in the
East Midlands
well Mr Speaker my honorable friend is a
tireless advocate for the East Midlands
and in particular I welcome the
Devolution deal that has been agreed
among the four local authorities in the
region something I know honorable friend
has campaigned for and like him I look
forward to those new devolved
institutions being established as soon
as possible to drive economic growth in
his community
well that was the conservative MP for
Mansfield Ben Bradley who seemed to be
putting the Prime Minister on a warning
that voters in his area were expressing
concerns about delivery by the
government where we can talk to Ben
Bradley now live from Mansfield uh Ben
good to see you thanks for joining us
you said you'd heard frustration from
voters during the local election
campaign just tell us more what were
they saying to you
hello good evening um yeah all sorts
really I think um summed up by that
frustration around delivery and the
prime minister's talked about his key
priorities for this year particularly a
number of economic priorities NHS uh
small votes and those things came up
obviously on the doorstep the thing I
was particularly raising today was that
leveling up agenda where I know in my
community there's been a huge amount of
government
um commitments in terms of townspun
leveling up fund and other projects uh
our East Midlands Devolution deal and
command Authority that's coming forward
but none of it's there yet we've got
lots of things in the pipeline and by
the next election people will expect to
see that bricks and more to the outcomes
of those things it must be frustrating
then to feel that your government isn't
yet delivering for your constituents
we've made some huge strides forward
um not intended to to
um kind of look past some of the really
positive things that we have managed to
achieve Manchester has become a
University Town in the last five years
with Nottingham Trent uh setting up the
campus on site we've got all sorts of
things as I said in the pipeline
Community Diagnostics Center coming out
way uh capital investment in the college
in the hospital there's some really good
stuff that has happened but in
particular I think one of the most
visible indicators of
um the direction of travel of a town is
its Town Center we've got 17 million
pounds worth of projects from the
government that are still in the
pipeline and still trickling along but
on a macro level
um that is Midlands combined Authority
that we've been working on now for 18
months I need the prime minister to get
the leveling up Bill through in a timely
fashion or that's going to the timeline
for that is gonna slip and that's worth
billions and billions of pounds to our
economy so we need to see that done why
do you think it's taking so long then
well the wheels of government
unfortunately turn uh very slowly I'm a
local Authority leader and it's the same
there at all uh levels I think that we
always want things to move faster than
they do I think some of these projects
because of our complicated structures in
the region
um which again our combined authorities
intended to try and help to tackle but
we've got multiple tiered local
government and all sorts of different
structures involved in decision making I
can go and try and secure funding from
government for things like the leveling
up fund and then I have to hand it over
to my labor District Council who have
yet so far failed to deliver those
outcomes and sometimes just aren't
equipped to be able to manage these
large projects so there is a lot of
trying to hurt the cats to try and get
things done which I've been trying very
hard to do and but the more that
government can drive at that that
delivery point both in terms of the
prime minister's key priorities and for
us the visible outcomes on the ground
those will be absolutely key in the next
election you're obviously a big
supporter of the East Midlands
Devolution deal but that has had its
critics Center for cities has said
um that they're concerned that it's step
backwards because it combines Derbyshire
and Nottingham it says it contains two
separate local economies Derby and
Nottingham in a single structure d2n2 is
not an economic geography and will
potentially create more problems than it
solves I mean isn't isn't this an
example of even more of that bureaucracy
and levels of funding that you were
talking about isn't this going to create
more issues
well if I'm honest I think the incentive
cities are talking nonsense we've had a
d2n2 as the it's called it's called that
because we've had a local Enterprise
partnership working on that geography
for the last
um decade or so so we already work in
that economic footprint It's Not Unusual
but we had originally planned to have
leicestershire involved as well but all
sorts of um issues in leicester's
internal Politics as to why that's not
happened but from our point of view I
see that very much as a way to start to
coordinate our multiple tiers of local
government we all will be forced to sit
around the table and do things together
which we've never done before and we
will have a significant extra investment
for our region in economic development
in transport infrastructure and other
key things to help us drive growth the
biggest challenge we've had in the past
is if you come and talk to the East
Midlands as a private business as an
investor in our region who do you talk
to there isn't an Andy Street and Andy
burn with Ben Houchin to go and see
you've got 18 different councils with 18
different views or competing against
each other so just having that focal
point for our region to draw in
investment will be hugely important I
think what about you'll see to the next
election we've seen the conservatives do
pretty badly in the local elections are
you worried about your seat if this deal
doesn't go through
well I think the the delivery point is
really important my constituents will
expect to see
um some of these outcomes some of them
we've got as I said we've become a
university town and others and some are
still in the pipeline like our new
hospital investment Community Diagnostic
Center like some of the Town Center work
so we've got
um time a little bit of time still to
deliver those but that will be really
really important and in my constituency
um Elite immigration is the biggest
thing that comes across my desk on a
weekly basis so I will be judged
massively on the prime minister's
success in that space as well but our
local elections were all right locally
we gained three seats and although labor
took control of the council their games
came from an independent party that kind
of died to death rather than from us
um I was elected in 2017 when we had no
Castle seats at all so we're in a much
better place than we were then
nationally it was clearly a struggle and
I do think you know the the biggest
thing I heard on the doorstep was you
talk a good game where are the outcomes
if the Prime Minister can deliver those
outcomes then I think we'll win if you
can't we'll struggle you'll have to hold
his feet to the fire Ben Bradley good to
talk to you thank you very much
well you're watching the take live from
Westminster up next we'll round up
everything we've heard so far and do
some post-match analysis
[Music]
foreign
welcome back live to Westminster you're
watching the take World we've had plenty
of takes this evening and let's have a
little post match Roundup with our
Deputy political editor Sam Coates who's
here again and of course you've been
closely watching our interviews of
course the Prime Minister would have
been closely watching at number 10 as
well this evening wouldn't he I'm sure
he always does or why has he had
something else on tonight I think this
week is a bit of an odd one because
we're after the local elections
everyone's having a little bit less of a
frenetic time than they might otherwise
have done if you want to know what Rishi
cynic is up to and he wants you to to
know that you have to look at his
official photographic account so let's
have a look at what Richardson is up to
tonight yes that is our prime minister
now I mean I know this is meant to sort
of say shout glamor it's meant to shout
Eurovision but it does shout to me Bingo
caller you know it's got number 22 you
know
um yeah Rishi Cena wants you to look
once you think he's looking like he's
having fun look he's in the crowd with
loads of people let's look at the next
picture uh that they released and and
with apologies this is a bunch of
Ukrainian families and pop stars all
gathered in number 10 and he he couldn't
look happier this is the image of Rishi
number 10 want you to see what they
don't want you to know is that just a
month ago he was asked about Eurovision
schools this week and he said I
generally don't have time for any of
those things so he might look like he's
enjoying it now but that's not
necessarily what he's doing and actually
but she says really interesting person
to be doing a bit of a dive into into
who he really is and what culture he
really likes with the help of The
Spectator that's revealed quite a lot
today did you know Jane what his
favorite taste in music is
[Music]
what kind of Television does he like
according to the specification
Emily in Paris which I don't watch but
I'm told you can watch uh scrolling
through your phone young children you
see is he kind of forced into that genre
by by the children who are in control of
the devices if it's a prime minister
being legislated by other people at the
forces of uh mercy of forces outside his
control that's not very good who is his
favorite author Jane
I don't know Julie Cooper
and his mind according to the spectator
Katie balls is Riders I tell about the
great and good Frolic in a fictional
Cotswold County of Russia infidelity
duplicity and Intrigue all played out in
conservative Heartland he's trying to
make us think he's all he's quite racy
your comment not mine let's look at
Clear Starman what he's been up to today
in a moment where's he gone where's he
gone oh he's not there okay
look at his official account uh bit of a
passion killer there uh there there he
is having Roundtable meetings with
councilors that won the local election
meetings with Bill Clinton that uh
account of photographs wants you to tell
you that he wants to be seen as a
government as a as a leader in Waiting
as somebody who could be prime minister
uh this guy wants to project an image of
fun it's quite an interesting tactic
will people warm to him or does it not
quite work
I couldn't possibly comment I just think
it's a really strange mix isn't it it's
a it's a salad of choices Sam great to
see you thanks so much for watching the
take Sophie's gonna be back next week I
bet you're relieved stay tuned use a
106.
[Music]
foreign